hallo mein name ist ich nehme auf ja
hallo mein name ist luca und alles klar
schaut euch mal schön die hand ich bin
gleich zu hause bei meiner familie und
habe mir gedacht was ist kann man nichts
machen was getan es war einfach der
stecker ding von meinem bitte dass ich
bin zu hause bei meiner familie und da
nehme ich ein mal die trailer videos auf
und allgemein macht mir das unglaublich
viel spaß und ich will viel öfter
reallife machen und macht mit der zeit
sogar viel mehr spaß als gaming deswegen
hab ich wieder gesagt jetzt irgendwas zu
sehen wir fangen direkt damit perfekt
genau solche einsendungen habe ich mir
ja gewünscht
auch an dich danke für deine tolle
einsendung ich bin's ultra cool wie man
auf solche sachen reagieren kann und
dass ihr so kreativ sein und ihr habt
irgendwie allen vogelnest da sendet mir
einen vogel 1 alles klar
was ist mit euch los also hab' den leben
luca vielleicht solltest du demnächst
den pickel nicht direkt vor der aufnahme
eines videos ausdrücken was ich kann das
auch
und wisst ihr wo man sowas kaufen kann
richtig
ich behalte die beta stück jetzt mein
charakter der kinos wie du du du bist da
hat einer richtig einen raus gehauen
liebe grüße von mir und ich danke dir
schöne grüße an dich zurück ich weiß
nicht wer mir das video eingesendet hat
es war zumindest nicht du ich weiß nicht
wie diese person hat wieder gekommen
aber hey baby freilich kann auch an die
pi rips
da ist richtig cool verfassen
ich kann nicht nutzen ich kann mir nicht
rütteln
ich weiß nicht ob das eine krankheit ist
ob das in vier krankheit ist ein böses
wort ich kann einfach nicht rüsten ich
weiß nicht warum aber ich kriege es
nicht hin ich kann alles aber ist ja
okay ich kann nicht anders eigentlich
nicht kann ich kann nichts so verbleiben
wir einfach mal was ich habe totale
probleme damit zurück nicht ich kann das
halt wenn ich was gegessen habe und so
oder wenn ich eine ganze cola getrunken
ab oder sowas aber so so können jetzt
nicht sagen einfach so langsam sollte
spaß ist so hering geblieben
die meinen also ich hab euch gesagt ihr
sollten unter dem hashtag luca luka auf
twitter einfach in welche videos seien
wirklich irgendwelche aber ich hätte
nicht mit so etwas gerechnet mir war
schon klar und es liegt noch unter dem
hashtag dass jedes mehr als jedes zweite
video irgendwie tomatensaft beinhaltet
hat deswegen habe ich das extra mehr
oder weniger ausgelastet diesmal und
dachte okay kommt mir das egal er geht
ein kühlschrank im zu schlagsahne raus
ich dachte es geht so zu ende dass er da
noch was anderes raus
noch was und dann irgendwann sie der sau
tomatensaft dann was das allerdings sind
ja einfach diese schlagsahne und
klatschte auf boden
ihr seid doch recht behinderter kauft
eine mutter irgendwie diese schlag sein
denkt sich hall mit backen kuchen
braucht man dafür schlagsahne und der
schlagsahne
guck mal hier ich wollte nicht das video
beenden aber ich habe noch gar keine
richtige frage waren wurde deswegen
machen wir jetzt noch fünf richtige
fragen ein verein ugra ich habe eine
frage an dich und du irgendwann mal
wieder
ich habe das ja schon mal auf meinem
kanal gezogen falls ihr das nicht wisst
weil ich immer viele leute sagen dass
ich zocken soll ich frage euch das hier
also hier könnt ihr draufklicken und da
ist jetzt das genre des video und da
habe ich halt schon mal gezockt deswegen
ist das ding so ein bisschen das ich
dann schon mal gezockt habe und viele
gamestop ich einfach noch einmal und das
game metallteile story deswegen zog ist
halt nur einmal wenn ihr jetzt die
kommentare zu spenden sagt luca zog die
geometrie dave dann mache ich es nochmal
aber ich weiß nicht ob das eine große
dass viele freuen sich jetzt mal so kam
eine frage an dich ist wenn du einen
neuen begriff einbürgern könnte den
genauso beliebt werden wir wie
tomatensaft welcher wäre das
vielleicht pizza alpaka erstmal würde
ich nicht sagen dass tomatensaft beliebt
ist also es ist halt immer so dass es
ihnen unter alle videos gesperrt das
sogar kelly davon videos zugesendet
bekommen mit tomatensaft das denn ich
sage schickt mir videos kommt von ich
glaube jetzt gerade wurden nach 20
minuten die 100 videos eingesetzt davon
waren 70 locker noch mit tomatensaft
inhalte das ganze wollte ich ja gar
nicht habe nur dieses video von stan
damals bekommen und hab dann gedacht und
tomaten sagt alles klar und dann habe es
hat immer mehr gemacht und immer mehr
und immer mehr und ich bringen
wahrscheinlich bei den tomatensaft raus
obwohl tomaten sagt es natürlich schon
nervt dass die game post gesagt wird
oder matze system mittelding also ich
finde wenn ich jetzt so videos dran
nehmen möchte einfach mal so ein cooles
video machen möchte mich auf eure videos
reagieren nervt mich so ein bisschen das
unglaublich viel halt einfach
tomatensaft ist allerdings finde ich so
die bewegung an sich einfach noch witzig
dass man einfach an so einem scheiß
tomatensaft so viel gefallen daran finde
ich meine ich habe es ja auch oft in
meiner cnet story endet mich persönlich
heiße bei snapshot laser luca da seht
ihr es eingeblendet das ist mein bild
ich poste bei snapshot so sachen wie
beispielsweise da haben wir bei den
prosieben event das catering gesucht
nicht mehr einfach einen raum rein
gelaufen umgeschrieben jedenfalls passt
ja auch da immer so wenn ich im flieger
sitzen und mehr tomatensaft bestellen
immer so tomaten alle machen so
screenshot und schickt mir sicher
automaten sagt wie witzigmann also ich
find die entwicklungen wie witzig aber
manchmal nervt mich auch und ich bin
folgen kann ich auf die frage richtig
eingegangen und zwar wenn ich den
begriff integrieren könnte er genauso
erfolgreich genauso bekannt wie die
tomaten hab ich weiß nicht begriffe die
ich selber übels ob sagen einfach so
josef man hitzer sage ich unglaublich
oft ein packer sage ich auch unglaublich
oft dass ein fachbegriff für die mich
irgendwie prägen weil ich liebe dich
lieber alpakas ich sage sie auf savy
sagt sie auch da ist sehr oft ich werde
nicht mehr richtig schminken ich habe
mal daran gedacht wirklich mit einer
freundin schminkt video aufzunehmen aber
damit macht man sich so zum affen
unfassbar es wäre locker witzig also
wenn ihr das wollt könnt ihr es ja mal
in die kommentare kritzeln kommen wir
jetzt auch schon zur letzten frage
alles klar da haben wir wieder den
tomatensaft mit drin wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich über einen
bewertungen freuen und dann würde ich
sagen habt ihr bock auf mehrere live
videos weil ich hab mir schon zu beginn
gesagt gaming macht mir jetzt gerade in
letzter zeit auch wenn das wetter
draußen da war geil es nicht so viel
spaß da will ich mich lieber irgendwo
auf dem balkon setzen und irgendwie euch
mal auch keine ahnung meine
schuhsammlung oder so zeigen oder halt
fragen beantworten oder solche videos
darauf reagieren oder so wenn ihr
weitere ideen für ihre videos schickt
mir in die schweiz mir in die kommentare
nicht nicht schicken und das ist halt
youtube man soll das machen worauf man
bock hat und ich habe halt derzeit nicht
so bock auf gaming und das vom locker
irgendwann wieder aber ich wollte jetzt
erst mal urlaub machen und dann
vielleicht so drei gaming videos pro
woche und zwar live videos
ich überlegte mir ein reines wieder
überschlagen ich spaß